[Musique]
le virus voyage comme nous il nous suit
partout on le dit et répété le corps
anna virus se propage surtout à travers
les gouttelettes mais sans doute aussi
dans l'air quand on monte dans l'avion
ou le métro ou bus qu'est ce qu'il
advient de l'air qu'on respire
dans quelle mesure le virus mute il
s'est retrouvé
d'abord on doit se dire que la
possibilité d'être infecté par un virus
contenu dans l'air dépend de deux choses
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de virus dans
l'air donc sa concentration et combien
temps je passe à cet endroit
mon exposition
prenez l'avion beaucoup de passagers une
grande proximité un petit habitacle clos
un vol de plusieurs heures en théorie la
recette parfaite pour la propagation du
virus dans l'air sauf que l'air est
renouvelée et filtré chaque bouffée
d'air dans un avion en vol est un
mélange à 50% des 9 séries de
l'extérieur mélangés à 50% des recyclés
de la cabine
l'air y est renouvelée toutes les deux à
trois minutes
l'air est aussi vitry dans cas des
avions raison ce sont des filtres à
haute efficacité capable de filtrer des
particules aussi petit que des virus
un filtre comparables à ceux utilisés
dans les hôpitaux et les salles blanches
dans le métro à montréal c'est tout le
contraire
l'air n'est pas filtré ni dans les
espaces publics et les tunnels ni dans
les wagons par contre le volume d'air
qui s'y trouve est démesurément plus
grands les virus qui s'y aventurent ils
sont beaucoup plus diluées leur capacité
d'effectuer une personne diminue aussi
avec le stress qu'ils subissent à
l'intérieur de la gouttelette qui les
transporte son assèchement rapide
provoquées par les mouvements violents
de l'air pu lui être fatale
c'est clair dans la station bien qu'il
ne soit pas filtré et très vite
renouvelée grâce aux veilles bien des
trains il a juste comme un méga de
piston qui tire sans arrêt leur neuf à
travers des puits de ventilation et des
portes papillon tout en repoussant l'air
vicié vers l'extérieur dans les wagons
les landes liant entre sans arrêt par
les ventilateurs du toit rsa par les
grilles latérales
[Musique]
l'autobus est un peu à mi chemin entre
le métro et l'avion comme dans la cabine
de l'avion c'est une combinaison dernier
fitial importants et des recyclés à 80 %
qui mélangé les filtrer avant de
circuler parmi les passagers
le port du couvre visage est obligatoire
tout au long de votre trajet
l'air qui circule dans le bus est filtré
chaque minute et demie environ
tous les rangs vian est complètement
renouvelée toutes les 7 à 8 minutes ou
plus rapidement avec l'ouverture
fréquente des portes
le système de filtration est différente
celui d evian il n'a pas été conçu pour
capter et filtrer les particules aussi
film on peut difficilement modifiés
après coup car plus on filtre plus on
crée de restriction au passage de l'air
est moins on ventile
par contre à la différence d'un vol en
avion la durée du déplacement en bus est
bien plus courte qu'en moyenne 25
minutes
[Musique]
on le voit le risque en voyageant
d'entrer en contact avec un virus dans
l'air n'est pas automatique
cela dépend de notre proximité avec la
personne infectée et de la capacité du
virus
elles meurent et infectieux dans la khl
le risque est d'autant plus réduit si
tous les passagers portent un masque
c'est le cas en ce moment dans les
avions les métro et les autobus
il sait sans compter que l'achalandage
dans les transports en commun est plus
faible entre 30 et 50 % de ce qu'il
était avant la pandémie
enfin il faut garder à l'esprit que le
virus peut aussi survivre un moment sur
certaines surfaces
alors il ne s'agit pas seulement de bien
ventiler les espaces mais aussi de
désinfecter régulièrement les endroits
où les messes pose le ne va pas sans
l'autre
et si tout prix de tous ses efforts
qu'on pourra perturber les projets de
voyages du virus
[Musique]